[Applause]
and finally new rules someone has to
tell me why the same film critics who
find every movie somehow lacking in woke
credentials are all in on top gun
maverick
a two-hour propaganda ad for defense
contractors militaristic jingoism and
bombing foreigners
every other movie that comes out all of
which are made by liberals for liberals
with ardent liberal intent
fall short
if the movie is about poverty
the director didn't grow up poor enough
to understand it if it's about being gay
it's not gay enough
asian not asian enough
female not enough agency
[Applause]
race don't even try
sidelining
whitewashing
colorism white saviorism no amount of
virtue signaling is ever virtuous enough
but somehow 96 of film critics love top
gun like a catholic priest love sleep
away camp
and
look i liked it too
it's fun it's nostalgic and tom cruise
has been such an ageless reliably
entertaining movie star for so long it
sometimes makes me think
jesus christ is there something to
scientology
[Applause]
but
if you're a film critic and you've been
making your life's mission to root out
the insufficiently liberal in cinema did
you not notice that top gun is a lot
about making war mongering sexy again
the weapons porn
the endless money shots of engines
burning jet fuel the big dick energy
the aircraft carriers dancing in the
sumptuous oily haze all to the manly
macho masculine sounds of kenny loggins
did you know that if the u.s military
were a country its fuel usage alone
would make it the 47th largest emitter
of greenhouse gases and gases in the
world our military is the world's
singest largest largest consumer of
petroleum it's fused so much smog you
can barely see the highway to the danger
zone
about that the next time you're watching
a flyover how we're destroying the world
to protect it
top gun pretends our best fighter is
still the f-18 but we spent 1.5 trillion
on the f-35 which has never worked and
never will and yet we still buy it it's
the hugo of fighter jets
there is nothing more bloated and
corrupt than the pentagon budget we
conflate
you may
we conflate defense with defense
contractors that's why their budget is
800 billion dollars more than the next
nine countries combined in 2003
it was 378 billion somehow we took two
wars off the books
but now need to spend twice as much
and on fighting who in top gun the enemy
is just called the enemy
we don't name them we never see their
faces we don't hear them talk who are
they that's not important
no
we don't know who we're bombing and we
don't care we're bombing someone awesome
you had me at america [ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
whose ass we are kicking is on a
need-to-know basis
god bless america and death too to whom
it may concern
sorry
enemy it's not about you it's about us
we have tom cruise and you don't
this is a dick measuring contest it
doesn't really matter who owns the other
deck as long as ours is longer
it's just so ridiculous the enemy it's
like having a movie called godzilla
versus none of your business
and
that's on purpose the people who made
this movie understood that we as a
nation right now are just too fractured
to even have a common enemy that we can
all agree on so they left it up to our
imagination who do you hate put them in
there
you and you would think that for a
nation like us that's been around a
while and been through some [ __ ]
together it wouldn't be this hard to
agree on a mutual bad guy
it
it used to be russia
and still could be but then republicans
started showing up and i'd rather be a
russian than a democrat t-shirts
and siding with putin
and liberals
you couldn't have the enemy be an arab
country that would be islamophobic
it can't be an asian country because
that would be racist
next you'll be blaming china for covet
that's right not even a pandemic could
unite us
covet couldn't do it
russia couldn't do it
china couldn't do it
not even amber heard could do it
[Applause]
you know the old cliche has always been
that if martians attacked it would be
the one thing that brings the whole
world together now
i don't think it would even bring
americans together the martians could
blow up the white house like in
independence day and half the country
would be cheering in the streets
when they said take us to your leader
we'd start killing each other over who
that is
[Laughter]
giant robotic tripods could be
vaporizing new jersey and republicans
would say this is what happens in
biden's america
it never happened when trump was in
office
democrats would point out how the death
lasers were disproportionately affecting
low-income communities and
people of color and
aoc would tweet stop demonizing the
martian x community
[Applause]
alex jones would call it a false flag
operation and accuse the people whose
heads were melted off of being crisis
actors
marjorie taylor greene would criticize
the jews for not using their space
lasers on the martians
and lindsey graham would volunteer for
the anal probe
you